[Music]
pan american world airways clipper
flight 100
nears its destination
it's an industry that has changed the
world and it's now
in crisis but is this
aviation's moment for a green reset kobe
has given an opportunity to build back
green and faster
the technology race is on there's
absolutely opportunity for
companies like us to change the world
here but are the runners fit for purpose
and will sustainable air travel cost
[Music]
more
val miftikov is the ceo of a company
committed to sustainable aviation of
course it's exciting
uh every time we're testing something
new
and today he's test flying a plane that
could potentially solve aviation's
biggest
challenge this is uh the world's largest
hydrogen electric aircraft flying right
now
or we hope for us achieving all the
performance
that we expect to achieve his vision to
fly
without polluting the skies okay let's
do it
one three four decimal nine three zero
seven two eight zero
okay let's do the max what will it do
in this plane hydrogen is being used in
a fuel cell
to run an electric motor producing zero
carbon emissions obviously the only
byproduct of
fuel cell operation is water so water
vapor gets out
into the atmosphere and it's pretty
harmless
without decarbonizing technologies like
hydrogen
aviation could be responsible for 22
percent
of the planet's emissions by 2050
because it can pack more energy into a
smaller space
hydrogen has recently overtaken electric
batteries
as the front runner in the race for
cleaner flying
within 15 years the manufacturing giant
airbus
plans to introduce planes that burn
hydrogen in engines as
fuel and the eu believes that by 2050
hydrogen technologies could reduce the
industry's carbon emissions by
up to 75 per cent
regions we actually looked early on at
different ways to bring sustainability
to aviation
hydrogen electric is the most efficient
and likely to be the lowest cost
out of all but there are plenty
of obstacles to overcome before these
hydrogen technologies are commercially
viable
for starters installing the
infrastructure to distribute and produce
hydrogen will be very pricey
at least 500 billion dollars by one
estimate
what's more hydrogen will need to be
produced sustainably
using renewable energy to split water
molecules
and on top of that hydrogen packs less
energy into a given volume than jet fuel
so powering long-haul flights will mean
extensive aircraft redesign
so you need bigger tanks you need to
change the shape of the airplane
um and then within the engine you need
more sophisticated heat exchangers
uh to deal with the hydrogen coming
through
airlines are fighting for the future of
their industry
the big problem for aviation is that
green technologies cost a lot of money
but there isn't much to go around as the
industry faces the worst economic crisis
in its history
and as environmental movements like
flight shaming
are on the up
some in aviation are committed to
greener skies
it's just they can't do it on their own
according to one of britain's leading
figures on climate change and energy
policy
i think the good news is that
the industry has really redoubled its
efforts
to decarbonize i think we are seeing
many examples of of leadership but we
may also need
you know government support in an
environment where
coveted 19 has very clearly hit the cash
flows
of the big incumbent players in a way
which was not their fault
even with government's help it will take
at least two decades before
hydrogen-powered planes are ready for
takeoff
to reduce emissions in the nearer term
aviation needs other
and options front runner has recently
emerged
since july the right engine of this
airbus a321
has been powered by biofuel sustainable
fuels are made from synthetic sources or
biological ones such as crops
algae or even waste
one of the great benefits of going down
the sustainable aviation fuel the
biofuel
or the synthetic jet fuel route is that
it's a drop in fuel
so that what happens at the airport
doesn't change
to pump up the flow of sustainable fuels
experts say governments need to offer
incentives to airlines
that could mean rolling out taxes on
dirty fuels
and making airlines buy a certain
proportion of cleaner ones
we have this chicken and egg problem as
we call it of
aviation companies who say we would love
to buy
sustainable aviation fuel if it was only
50 more expensive than conventional jet
fuel
but as long as it's three times more
expensive this is prohibitively
expensive
and you have people trying to develop a
uh sustainable aviation fuel
technologies who would say we could get
the price down
if only we had certainty of
really big orders by a particular date
and there's another way governments
could speed up the shift to greener
skies
stumping up investment funds
so that's interesting just ask the ceo
who's trying to make hydrogen-powered
planes take off
he says the 3.3 million dollars his
company received from the british
government
has been crucial he argues larger scale
investment from the state
as well as the private sector is key to
making green aviation viable
it's very hard to make the
radically new technologies competitive
commercially without government support
right from the beginning
especially when you're in r d phase
especially in the
such a capital intense industry as
aviation going green may be the biggest
challenge the industry has ever faced
it demands the right investment and
policies to support a range of
technologies
and that might mean passengers need
deeper pockets
it may be that there is a slight
air ticket premium i think we should
simply pay it i said we should say this
is what we have to pay
in order to have zero carbon flight
[Music]
i'm simon wright industry editor at the
economist
if you'd like to read more about the
future of aviation click on the link
opposite
if you'd like to watch more of our now
and next series click on the other link
thank you for watching and don't forget
to subscribe